I always like to ask my audience when
you think about land snails what's the
very first word that pops into your head
just one word hello yes what else
slimy what else holes in your knees so
damage to your garden a little more
background on me I do work full-time at
Cornell University in a non snail
related position however I am also an
unpaid research associate at
paleontological research institutions
and Delaware Museum of Natural History
before I go further I get this question
all the time what are slugs slugs are
snails I define part of my mission as
the spokesperson for land snails my goal
is helping people become ecologically
literate about snails this is my
volunteers they're from a garden and I
don't know what they are okay but I
suspect they're all the same
okay look very familiar like mostly what
is in my garden all right let's see what
you got here looks like you have o arian
sub fuscus and they're commonly known as
the dusky Arian dusky this is what's
been eating your garden huh big time
yeah I'm sorry
well that's really cute it's $12 but I
think I might have to get this
definitely want this oh the kitchen set
with a stove and an oven and a teapot
what do you think of that Oh didn't like
that it's actually a little bit bigger
scale than the pieces we have for the
kitchen already I make scenes for my
snails it's a snail I mean a real smell
yeah sure it's a real snail it's just a
creative pursuit oh and they're not
afraid of you no I haven't done a lot of
clothing for the snails yet but once
they start having a collection of snail
clothes maybe they could use a sewing
machine we're going to get this
beautiful wood stove shot always
browsing yes literally how did this
hobby come about to me it's going to
bring awareness to the land snails well
as those are not something people think
of as beautiful but it might cause a
conversation about land snails that
maybe it wouldn't have happened if they
didn't see this silly little scene with
snails in it the first thing you wonder
when you see them shopping around at the
scene tray is what do they eat
land snails and slugs are eating so low
foodweb they're consuming detritus and
they're gleaning essential nutrients the
snail is passing calcium up through the
food web and supplying it to all these
animals that's how important sales are
birdies can't lay eggs without calcium
you got it some snails are going extinct
and this is of concern because you have
potentially reduced numbers of the snail
predators if my role is to help snails
become appreciated in the world I find
that I have to look at certain points of
entry into their world
[Music]
the upper tentacle of a snail has two
different sensory organs in it has the
eye and it also has olfactory sensors at
the end of it which are for smelling and
tasting when the snail is waving this
tentacles around as it travels its seen
and it's smelling and it's tasting well
at the same time as a science
illustrator I feel like I'm somebody who
is communicating the parts and the
meanings of the snail to a wider
audience when I look at snails moving
their tentacles I know the position of
the tentacles I know what they look like
in reality and I go stirred in many tons
but when I'm doing something that's more
free I want to put some more life into
it some more expression and movements
the way they move its poetic it's like
snail ballet it's a slow thoughtful
looking and sensing and smelling and
really taking in the environments
[Music]
just seems natural since I very much
like listening to what snails have to
tell the world I think that qualifies me
as a snail Wrangler the snails are not
trainable the way dogs are or horses or
growths or other animals
I think what's now is it's more
understanding their behavior and
thinking about what they're going to
like and not like snails are bothered by
dry heat and they might be bothered by
certain chemicals and surfaces a lot of
it is looking out for the well-being of
the snails themselves if snails need a
break to have sex we might just have an
orgy on this tray land snails are
hermaphroditic so they actually have
both male and female reproductive parts
this part of the ritual of snails have
to move away from each other and circle
around and go back again the lowest man
might do it tail bite
[Music]
fighting fighting you can see on the
right of the foot - subverting its penis
[Music]
one did to stab a love dart in so the
white bit that you see at the end of a
love dart love darts are thought to you
enable each snail to retain the sperm of
its partner better
[Music]
[Music]
what a beautiful native dance I can't
remember a time when I didn't really
love snails when I was a child I really
liked to overturn the landscaping stones
and when you turn over a stone you see
pill bugs and millipedes and you also
see snails but to see the snails you
have to look much more closely than you
might otherwise because most snails are
really tiny no idea that they're so tiny
actually in North America ninety-five
percent of the snails are smaller than a
lentil
[Music]
we have these tiny Vilonia snails one
here and here and here and here as a
child I was searching for library books
that would give me some answers about
what I was finding there really weren't
any so I think since I was a really
young child I've been on a quest to
learn more ready to begin our lesson the
idea is that one snail will act as
professor today get the professor snail
to stay I've got your heart when the
sail eats its food it uses the rajala
there are many rows and columns of tiny
tightness teeth on the rajala the snail
can move the rajala out of its mouth and
scrape the food anybody wants carrots
raise your upper tentacle when I was
very young I would hold my snails up to
my ear while it was eating and I would
hear the slightest little sound and I
told all my friends in school I can hear
the snail in and then I was bullied for
the next 10 years and I couldn't let
this go and I felt that someday there's
going to be a way I can show people how
the sound of a snail is
oh it's doing it there's definitely
something there
[Music]
yes we've got snail sound
our ears are sensitive enough to hear
down to about 40 DB and this is not the
asleep about that there's a lot of low
frequency portion to this it makes me
think that from the perspective of what
they'd be able to put unquote here that
actually lines up with something that
would be lower frequency even those
nails don't really hear the way we do
they don't have ears
they have stat assists which have tiny
cilia
tiny tiny microscopic hairs and those
hairs can pick up vibrations so I hope
that the snails enjoy my music
[Music]
the way as I moves from retracted inside
the tentacle pushing itself out that's
what inspired this music to me that
action is sort of like an octave when
the snails eye is inverted that's the
low note and then as the hydrostatic
pressure pushes the snails eye out of
the tentacle to me that's like going up
and often I think piano is a little
percussive for snails and that's the
reason I'm learning the cello
I feel like cello is the instrument for
snails
[Music]
[Music]
it's such a mellow sounding instrument
and it vibrates just so beautifully the
tone of the cello and the range of the
cello on the musical scales is really
beautiful it just feels right for snails
for me somehow
[Music]
if you are grossed out by the snails
body if you just think about the spiral
shell it is beautiful so if nothing else
if people appreciate the spiral shell I
think that's a good starting point so
sometimes in my artwork I just like to
draw spirals lots of spirals and you can
sort of get lost in a spiral and enjoy
it in its natural perfection you can
tell the age of snails by how developed
their adult shell characteristics are
when I was in graduate school I
collected a Meza done the latest snail
but at the time it was such a juvenile I
actually didn't know its species name
but I decided since it wasn't useful
data for my a study that it was just a
juvenile snail I thought I'm gonna grow
it up and see what it becomes I still
have that snail it's ten years old as an
artist and an illustrator I very much
like to draw from the snail it's hard to
put into words it's hard to explain why
this snail is special not only because
it's lived for this many years but it's
been a companion to me during hard times
and it's been a good friend
a spiritual advisor of my name to this
now
she said it's wise beyond its body and
its form and that's why she named it
mystery fault I have learned patience
from Lance now
I've learned meditation from land snails
I've learned to be really still and feel
the Infinity in every second in every
nanosecond
I think this world has too much brush
and carelessness in it now where we all
try to multitask and when I think about
snails I think about what's important
and I think about slowing down and being
in the moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]